how has quarantine been for you like
what are you doing
just in your life what are you doing
like what the heck is keith urban doing
in court i'm gonna chat with keisha
making a fire album
thank uh i wish i could i can't cook
i really wish i could cook how many
things did everybody
say they're gonna do with this lockdown
period ago i got months to learn a new
language or a new skill and did
nothing and
[Music]
making having a studio at the house
made the finishing of the record
possible and the other thing i realized
through this period
was getting back to being creative with
limited
resources unlike keith urban's house
even in the opening track out the cage
that i did with breeland
there were so many things i wanted to do
on that record recording-wise i wanted
this
50-person choir at the breakdown section
of the song and wanted an orchestra here
and of course they're like well that's
not happening so what else we're going
to do
and breeland who's a great singer who
said well what about i stack all the
vocal parts like
i'll be the choir and so we recorded his
vocals like over 50 times
singing everybody's part in the choir
multi-tracking
and the end result was amazing but it
was all born of limitation like okay
well we got to use what we got in front
of us
what kind of music are you listening to
is there anybody that inspires you or
any shows that you're watching that
you're just loving
oh my gosh well we got we got way deep
into uh succession how are things
between you and your dad
um pretty good he looks demented why is
he so shiny
we're waiting for that to get back into
production as i'm sure they are
um tour through um
oh you can't even say shit's creek can
you i was both shocked and impressed
yes you can there it is i just said it
torn through that
and we love it
oh my gosh uh what have we been loving
lately
um oh yellowstone i don't believe in
destiny
you're right even you aren't that naive
you know musically gosh there's always
something coming out whether it's uh
duolipus new record which i love the
weekend's new record it's
fantastic great things on the new chicks
record
taylor's whole new album i love
she's taking her songwriting to a whole
new level she's phenomenal
so a lot of great stuff out there right
now